وفي العاصمه الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا يجري
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك
عجار لقاءات مع مسؤولين اثيوبيين واخرين
في الاتحاد الافريقي تركز على الازمه
السودانيه وسبل وقف اطلاق النار وبدء
الحوار بين المتحاربين كما يبحث يبحثوا
الاوضاع الانسانيه
وانعكاسات الحرب على المدنيين والمبادرات
والجهود المبذوله لايقاف الحرب في السودان
ناديس مكتب الجزيره محمد طه توكل محمد ملك
عجار هو عمليا اخذ مكان محمد حمدان حمادته
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده في السودان
ولكنه في ذات الوقت الان
يجري جهودا لوقف الحرب بين الطرفين
دون انحياز على الاقل من خلال التصريحات
التي يدلي بها ما الذي سوف يفعله في
العاصمه الاثيوبيه
نعم عثمان هو قام بجوله شملت كينيا اوغندا
وجنوب السودان وهذه محطه مهمه محطه اديس
اباسه يلتقي طبعا اثيوبيا دوله جاره
للسودان حيلتقي حسب المصادر التي
علمنا منها انه هيلتقي غدا في لقاء مع
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي اليوم مع المسؤولين
في الاتحاد الافريقي وخاصه المعنيين بملف
السودان في الاتحاد الافريقي طبعا كما هو
معلوم عثمان هناك اللجنه الاليه الموسعه
التي تدم 21 دوله زايد
منظمه الايقاد والجامعه العربيه والاتحاد
الافريقي
والامم المتحده فاللقاءات اهم لانه سيجري
مع كل الفاعلين المؤثرين
بشان ملف الازمه السودانيه وهو طبعا يعتبر
مالك عقار الذي
ينتمي الى اقليم محادي لايسوبيا وكان من
قاده الجبهه الثوريه من المعارضين الان
هذه المره للمره الاولى يدخل مش فقط
السفاره السودانيه بل هو في بيت الضيافه
التي كانت خصبا عليه قبل اقل من 3 سنوات
كان احد من قاده الحركات المسلحه فبالتالي
ياتي لشرح الموقف ومن هنا سيتجه الى
جابوتي حيث تنعقد قمه ايجاد سيجري لقاءات
مع المسؤولين في منظمه حتى هذه اللحظه
عثمان لا توجد تفاصيل دقيقه ولكن هناك
تحديات كبيره وقف اطلاق النار في زله
انعدام الاتفاق وانهيار وقفه النار الذي
تم برعايته السعوديه وامريكا فبالتالي
مالك عقار الذي يتراس وفد بلاده في قمه
ايجاد
سيبحث مع
الاليه الموسعه او خارطه الطريق التي
طرحها لانه سيكون اول مسؤول سوداني يبحث
ملف الازمه مع المسؤولين على الافارقه
والاسوبيين عثمان نعم ابقى معنا محمد